let's try our caller from the five seven zero
area code.
Who's calling today from five seven zero
Jordan from Pennsylvania.
Hey Jordan.
What's going on?
Well, there's a wall of anger about censorship
online, social media.
And I've thought about something.
The government forms of roads, the government
from the library and other social services.
Why can't they fund a public access internet?
It's non
commercial.
Some places go on, you're protected by the
law.
Some places have it
and you can just, why can't I do it?
All whole national thing.
And that takes the place of youtube and all
that other stuff.
Well hold on a second.
You're confusing two things now.
So Youtube is a platform, not, not an Internet
service provider.
And by the way, I'm hearing my own voice echoing
back, so if I'm on speaker, please, please,
please take me off.
Are you talking about the government running
a social media platform or the government
running the Internet utility?
Both.
Oh, okay.
I don't know that I see the advantage of the
government necessarily running the social
platform, although it's an interesting idea.
But there are places like for example, out
in western Massachusetts and New York where
the show started, there's a place called leverage
and lever it and maybe it's Shutesbury, maybe
it's both.
Uh, they're really small places, so they're
not that interesting for like Comcast to come
into, but they have municipal broadband, they
have established municipal broadband services
that the town owns it.
It's cheaper than what a lot of the for profit
companies provide.
That's super interesting to me.
I guess I haven't given much thought to the
government, like a government, Facebook or
youtube.
I don't know that I, I'd have to think more
about that.
But the government getting involved in running
some of these utilities, or at least the regulation
of these utility of these Internet service
providers as utilities, which is part of net
neutrality ideas.
That is very important.
And I would be very much supportive of that.
Yeah.
Because there's a lot of anonymous people
harassing and people are trying to make a
quick dollar and I think the Internet would
be better for the intellectuals if you've
got rid of that
you, but are you saying you, you want all
websites to be run by the government?
I mean it's, it sounds a little a little crazy.
No, you would have an option.
You can either go the public library or it
goes a bookstore and pay your choice.
Yeah.
So there would be an, there would be an internet
where the content is run by the government
and then another internet where people can
put up the stuff they want.
Yeah.
Regulated by the government.
And you're protected by the first amendment.
Something like a public access.
Totally.
I don't know that it totally works, but because
you know, there's already websites that are
run by all sorts of people, governments and
individuals, but the municipal broadband piece
is, is really important and I'm, I'm very
much behind that.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.
I hope to hear from you again.